imagine being inside of there where
everywhere you look you're you're feel
like you're literally part of the story
and you're inside the story you're not
only seeing but you're feeling you're
feeling with your body uh whether it's
the flying or motion you know's imagine
flying on the back of a dragon and
feeling the wind in your face and
smelling uh the smell of the Pine Forest
that you're flying over these kind of
things just add to a much deeper level
uh of immersion which I think is very
exciting you know because ultimately a
lot of Storytelling uh is about
vicariously living that experience you
know through the character's uh uh own
experience welcome to 20-minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
[Music]
started this episode is parted by J
Ventures a community-driven VC Fund in
silon Valley in partnership with litech
and sponsored by Homewood Ventures hippo
Insurance upwest hell at Stanford leap
and Birthright Excel and in media
partnership with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders and today
we're going to be talking about media
entertainment and different kind of
experiences than we're used to meet
Jeffrey Travis the CEO of positron
Jeffrey is an entrepreneur filmmaker and
engineer he's the founder of positron
where he leads a team that is building
the future of immersive Cinemas with
voyager the world's first full motion
chair for cinematic VR he has worked
closely with Studios such as universal
DreamWorks and Disney and companies such
as Intel Verizon and Walmart to
integrate VR content into multi-sensory
experiences for audiences around the
globe Jeffrey is passionate about
elevating storytelling through VR and AR
and immersive
Technologies Jeffrey Travis how are you
welcome to 20-minute leaders thank you
so much for joining me thank you Michael
for having me excited to be on the the
podcast with you I'm really excited to
have you here and I I have some really
you know interesting stories that that
I've been hearing over over these you
know different episodes and and I get to
dive deep into these different
Industries and verticals and one of the
things that I just love most is when I
get to talk to somebody that is working
on something so cool and so you know
futuristic that I can just picture
myself using the product and seeing my
nieces as they grew up using it and so
today you're the you're the CEO of
positron and you're rethinking the way
that we we we get entertainment with
virtual reality in a cinema setting and
so I'm going to let you describe it a
little bit better than I can but but
with that you know I'd also have to
learn a little bit about you so jeery
tell me a little bit about positron and
then I'd like to go back and hear about
your own journey and how you ended up
working in this
world sure sure yeah no happy to happy
to talk about that so um our company
positron is building the platform for
what we call the future of Cinemas uh
immersive Cinemas um we're very focused
on virtual reality at the moment we
think that um you know VR axr is um the
next medium in terms of how we will be
consuming um all kinds of entertainment
you know movies for the last 100 plus
years have been shown on flat screens
and they're going to continue to be
doing that for hundreds of years just
the way that live theater never went
away but VR presents a new storytelling
medium that we're only beginning to see
um how creators and filmmakers uh can
take advantage of that and a lot of
people associate VR with games and
obviously that's that's a huge Market my
background is as a filmmaker and an
engineer so I'm particularly more
interested in the narrative storytelling
so Pon builds uh motion chairs that go
into locations like museums uh existing
Cinemas um uh retail settings even theme
parks where people can sit and
experience a full immersion of being
inside of the film so it has motion
haptic scent as well as the VR headset
and uh the kind of content that we're
showing are from creators that are
making groundbreaking VR works at
festivals like Sundance can Tribeca
we've also worked with a lot of the
Hollywood Studios we here in LA and so
uh we've done content with universal
Dream works uh Disney made their very
first commercial VR film based on the
Frozen 2 franchise that was shown on our
platform um so we're really excited
because it's very much at the Forefront
uh and you know today very few people
even know what I'm talking about if I
say a VR Cinema but we hope that in five
years that'll you know be just as common
as saying let's go to the movies let's
go uh let's go to our local you know
immersive Cinema can you tell me a
little bit about more about you know how
you perceive entertainment you know a
few years done on the line you know
perhaps a different generation of
entertainment you know and and if you
were perhaps to even explain to my niece
who's 7 years old today how you think
she's going to experience Cinema you
know as a teenager what what can we
expect sure yeah I think what we can
expect is you know for for your niece
for her uh going to the cinema is going
to be something that um involves a lot
more sense of all of her senses and
immersion you know so if you think about
how you know movies about Sight and
Sound right for for the last ever since
there was sound added to pictures you
know and that and that still can create
very powerful emotional connections you
know we we go on these like thrilling
adventures in an Avengers film or or
moov by drama but imagine being inside
of there where everywhere you look
you're you're feel like you're literally
part of the story and you're inside the
story you're not only seeing but you're
feeling you're feeling with your body uh
whether it's the flying or motion you
know's imagine flying on the back of a
dragon and feeling the wind in your face
and smelling
uh the smell of the Pine Forest that
you're flying over these kind of things
just add to a much deeper level of
immersion which I think is very exciting
you know because ultimately a lot of
Storytelling uh is about vicariously
living that experience you know through
the character's uh own experience so um
for her I think it'll be a lot of going
to a place where um it's not just
watching a screen but uh using the
technology to to kind of take her into
this magical place now as we're
transitioning there you know you're and
you're mentioning being frozen to and
you're mentioning working with Hollywood
and these different Studios what does it
actually take to transition from this 2D
or even 3D experience and transitioned
now into a
multi-sensory you know with motion
chairs and virtual reality what what do
you need to do as a technologist and now
as an entrepreneur to to make that
happen you know yeah a lot of it is
around um you know we're we're actually
just kind of riding a lot of the wave of
the the advances and uh game engines to
frankly so much of the uh even the
Hollywood traditional Productions are
going toward as what we call virtual
production where you're using uh things
like Unreal Engine from epic games or
Unity um and these are the same tools
that we use uh for creating uh a lot of
VR experiences um so these these sort of
tools enable um the the creators in the
studio to create essentially 3D worlds
there where I can as a director re
reposition the camera carry you through
and take you into this world um a good
example is when we worked with
DreamWorks on the How to Train Your
Dragon VR experience a lot of the
digital assets of the animation already
existed as 3D elements and so we were
able to bring those into VR and then
design a camera path that would fly you
through the adventure um and then the
chair the motion system is just it's a
simple programming of looking at where
should I turn and how should I make your
body feel like like you're flying so
it's it's a it's a new process but it's
also building on top of um so much of
what companies you know um like unreal
or epic games and even Facebook um you
know Microsoft uh HP are doing in terms
of uh that as they're building out this
VR technology and what lately has become
called the metaverse of course U which
is the big buzz word these days now is
this instead of the traditional way of
experiencing film or is this a different
experience that I will need to decide
today I want to experience one way or
another way or so in other words is this
sort of an evolution or a revolution
I think it's I you know I would call it
a revolution in the sense that I don't I
think it's going to be an entirely new
medium you know that I don't believe
this is going to replace traditional
film entirely you know the same way that
um you know uh television film did not
kill radio or even you know podcasts uh
which is known today um you know the
invention of Cinema did not kill Live
Theater we may see potentially a
diminishment in terms of audience
participation and what would be the more
traditional 2D films um I think there's
always going to be an uh these art forms
just like photography right don't don't
entirely go away so I I don't see uh
immersive films replacing traditional
films but I do see it as a revolution in
terms of here's an inal new medium and
this if you think about this really only
happens um every few maybe hundreds of
years right like like the last time we
had this Evolution was the invention of
um the motion picture camera right that
that went from still photographs to
Motion Pictures perhaps another re was
adding sound to pictures we're at the
same cuss which is really exciting right
because uh it's very few times in
history you sort of see this this
tectonic shift in terms of a medium that
uh creators can now work with now as an
entrepreneur and as the leader of of
pyron you know you're you're you're
bringing this new reality what is this
like for you I mean what are the biggest
challenges that you then need to face is
it more of the you know the
technological challenges of Simply
making the adaptations is it more of the
you know the the the Ed educ educating
the market the consumer Behavior behind
this what what are you faced
with yeah I think I think a lot of it is
you know that the challenges of we're
we're we're kind of working with uh so
many different pieces right the the
hardware component of our pods uh the
Software System new kinds of content and
being able to coales that into a a
unified experience um and then it's one
of these things where whether it's
pitching investors or you know the the
marketing it's it's sometimes
challenging to describe what it is
without you experience it you just have
to experience it yourself 100% of people
who experience it our assistant or pod
get out and go oh my gosh this is it I
get it I've seen the future uh if you
don't experience it you can see photos
you can see our website I can try to
describe it to you but it's very very
difficult uh to create that that sort of
aha moment so you know uh I think part
of the challenge is honestly just
figuring out how do we do the marketing
of this how do we do the message and so
um part of my goal is to build as many
um uh places as possible where people
can experience this type of uh VR film
and immersive Cinema um we're going to
be having at least eight locations open
by the end of the year and as more and
more people get to experience it I think
then it's sort of okay now now I get it
uh creators have a way to monetize this
kind of content consumers uh get
something that they cannot get at home
it's not a it's not something you can
just stream uh on your iPad and um it it
gives people a taste of what's to come
and from there we would like to you know
scale what we're doing today so so who's
harder to educate the you know the the
the investors the the cinema areas with
the locations where you're going to be
putting it in the filmmakers from
Hollywood or the people that are
actually going to experience the
entertainment who who is how do would
you rank from like sort of the easiest
to perceive this future to the
hardest yeah great question I would say
in some ways it's the locations you know
like like unless they've tried it it's
hard for them to know what they are uh I
think for consumers a lot of times they
they seem to intuitively get it you know
they see a visual or we explain and you
know the audience and consumers are
eager to experience something new even
if they don't know quite what it is yet
um I would say the easiest is is really
the creators filmmakers you know that
the people who are at the Forefront of
um working with storytelling and
Technology uh really do understand this
and in fact if anything their challenge
with how do I get this content out there
you know we were um fortunate enough to
have stepen Spielberg uh sit in our one
of our chairs and I got to with him a
little bit and just seeing you know he's
obviously like film royalty right
something someone I grew up as a child
watching all his films and you know to
see him at his you know stage in life
and AG he has completely grasped how VR
Works he was the executive producer on a
Jurassic world VR film that we had on
our chair and we talked a lot about the
technology and so you know it's it's
it's great to see that a lot of the you
know both young and more uh older
creators who have been around a long
time are embracing this
and really it's just about we're trying
to bridge that gap of how to get this
type of magical experience and content
to the to the
audiences and so now you know a little
bit more about you you mentioned that
you're a filmmaker and you're a writer
and you know you transition to more
thinking more strategically in the
entertainment world what what was that
transition like for you and what made
you make this transition from working on
a specific piece to now figuring out
okay can we create an experience that
will translate other writers pieces into
a whole new exper
experience yeah great question so I you
know um the way that this this
transition happened is I um had had an
opportunity to direct a a commercial
short film for Tesla VR film that this
was about six years ago in 2015 wow you
it was very early with the technology it
was like those you know phone gear vrs
um and what I noticed was that you know
the VR film I think turned out okay and
it was it was good to watch in our
studio but when we took it to locations
like the Tesla stores or generally you
know a lot of people I found were
getting a little bit nauseous or motion
sick in certain scenes um you know they
were sitting on bar stools kind of aware
there's other people around them and I I
just thought that the experience was not
good and and as a filmmaker Creator I
was very disappointed that after all the
work of making this the way it was being
exhibited or shown um really was
distracting you know and took away from
the experience there were all these you
know problems in terms of from motion
sickness to um not having a full sense
of immersion and so uh that kind of
prompted me to say hey we got to figure
out a way to solve this this is a
problem for me it's going to be a
problem for everybody else trying to
make VR films so I had some experience
as an engineer working with motion
simulators and I built this pod that um
you know was something that we would
create as a personal VR theater um and
that ended up um is launching positron
we we showed that at Sundance and had
Universal Studios as our first client
say hey we want to order 20 of those for
a a film we just did with Tom Cruz uh
from the mummy movie um and that's kind
of what launched the idea of a cinematic
VR theater wow so how much of your time
do you spend you know tangibly
day-to-day installing these locations
and and getting feedback on the on these
actual you know these actual you know
experiences versus thinking
strategically about okay how do I
actually get this at Mass scale and what
do I need to do as as you know the
leader of this triip to get this to
scale to potentially the entire us or
the entire
world yeah you know it's it's uh it is
one of those things where it um I think
it's all about building a great team you
know like uh F finding ways to think
about how do we scale this what what are
the kind of people and team that we need
to do this um is where I kind of spend a
lot of my time thinking you know that
that we want to we want to scale this uh
you know not just in the US but but
globally um in a lot of ways become what
IMAX was able to do for large format
Cinema we want to become that same sort
of standard for VR Cinema um so you know
really a lot of my time is uh spent
thinking about uh where things are going
understanding um how the VR technology
continues to evolve very very fast um uh
keeping up with that and then secondly
just um you know trying to build a great
team as we go along we've been fortunate
to have a great team of people who have
uh deep engineering backgrounds have
artists I think really part of the what
makes us successful and unique is we are
combining both in engineering talent and
uh creative artistic talent together on
the same team and bringing kind of that
left brain and right brain thinking um
to to our product and to how we're going
to scale is is um I I believe it's going
to be part of uh the the path to Our
Success so is the vision or or you know
would you what would you consider a
success for positron is it more you know
feeling that you've shifted the consumer
behavior is it more you know being the
one to go and and and make these changes
both to the actual films and adapting
them to to these new experiences what is
sort of the kpi that you keeping in the
back of your mind you know as you
running Venture sure I I think really
that the kpis that for us success will
really ultimately measured by you know
having uh we we our our vision goal is
10,000 chairs around the world that are
wow obviously being used all the time
right 10,000 pods uh where from a
consumer's mind you know right this is
where you go see it's a distribution
Network so to have that at a scale that
makes sense um you know it's really
really building that first cinematic VR
distribution Network and eventually we
may be going into the home and and
finding ways that are not just our
chairs but digital distribution but we
think that location-based entertainment
is the place to start so having 10,000
chairs around the world we're um you
know we're about 5% of the way there so
get getting there but uh you know it's
that's that's the vision I I love it now
if you go back a little bit in time you
know even Middle School elementary
school is it always about entertainment
always about storytelling what what
really fascinated you growing up oh yeah
great question you know I I think when I
was very young I was actually really
fascinated by um magic so I loved magic
shows um I remember for like the the
talent shows in elementary middle school
I would uh uh find some some magic
tricks to do uh even in in college I was
very interested in in Magic as a
performing art um so so the answer is
yes I think there was that aspect of
entertainment uh and I also always loved
um writing I grew up reading um a lot of
literature started writing some of my
own stories from poetry um and then
later on some screenplays and so I think
the power of story to to move us and
transform us but also there's something
about um magic when done right is is
just creates that sense of awe and
wonder of something that um you know the
world is is more than my own small world
it kind of opens up people to uh I think
it opens their hearts and Minds in ways
that um is very unique and so I think
maybe that was some of the beginnings of
wanting other people to experience that
same sense of awe and wonder that I
would feel when either seeing some magic
or being UN rpur in a story is in some
ways what I'm still trying to do today I
love it and if you look today what you
do dayto Day More broadly where do you
get your your inspiration from and and
obviously you know the Grand Vision is
very inspiring on its own but you know
where do you draw this simple day-to-day
inspiration for what you do
yeah yeah great question you know it
really is around where I draw
inspiration is um from art good good art
good storytelling so I make it a point
every week uh and it doesn't have to be
VR right but I do watch a lot of VR
content um I find it incredibly
inspiring we're uh watching some of the
latest works from Venice Film Festival
every year the the creative Works gets
better and better this is something that
most consumers don't get to see and this
is part of why I'm passion like bringing
this to bigger audience but sometimes
for me it's also um you know I read uh a
lot of poetry and I find inspiration in
um poetry as well as Visual Arts uh
sitting with that and and kind of that
letting someone else's visioner or you
know something they were trying to say
uh have move me and and and I just find
that that's part of really what makes us
uniquely human right is is the ability
to to create art so and so as you're you
know working with your team what what do
you find you know both most rewarding
and perhaps challenging leading a team
you know in in this Vision cuz this is
not an or an ordinary startup right I
you know I think what I find most
rewarding is to see uh on the team
different people from different
backgrounds and we have a very um
diverse team both in terms of background
and just uh both professionally and
personally where people come from and
seeing the very rewarding part is seeing
this all come together behind a vision
right when we go to for example a new VR
theater we've installed and we're
watching people walk in and they don't
know that we're necessarily part of
pitron right and seeing the look on
their faces when they come off and talk
about it it's it's it's seeing that team
come together I think the the
challenging part is you know um these
particularly right now in these times as
you probably know it's finding great
talent attracting is is more challenging
than it's been in the past the pandemic
has made a lot of people you know choose
alternate careers or or or look for
other things to do so finding ways to
continue building our team um sometimes
can be can be challenging just because
we you know
we're we're working with hardware and so
it's not so easy for us to have a remote
work team you know you have teams who
hey I can work from anywhere in the
world some of the roles we have you
could work from anywhere but some of
some of the roles really have to be uh
here on the ground and so um I find that
that's a bit challenging for us is that
you know we're a more traditional
in-person uh office uh for the most part
and what are a few words that you would
use to describe
yourself oh good question I would say um
words to describe myself uh creative uh
hopeful and um I would say uh ambitious
so Jeffrey thank you very very much this
was wonderful best of luck with pitr I
can't wait to see to see it and
experience it myself I I can only think
of the future and I'm excited for this
next generation of entertainment and and
I'm really happy to have spoken to one
of the pioneers of it and people that
are pushing it forward and then
hopefully sit in one of your chairs one
day so thank you very very much and stay
safe and stay healthy
oh